vous avez sans doute appris les lois du
mouvement de newton détroit loin de
mouvements de newton ce que j'aimerais
vous faire comprendre aujourd'hui besoin
c'est un peu ce que disent ces lois je
veux vraiment que vous les comprenez pas
jusque vous les appreniez et pour cela
je vais vous montrer les erreurs de
raisonnement que l'on fait constamment y
compris une fois qu'on a appris à la
théorie les erreurs qui ont fait
constamment quand on réfléchit à la
mécanique et à la physique autour de
nous je commencer par vous expliquer les
trolls à de newton un peu plus cool si
je pense un petit peu et je suis monté
dans un bus th parisien n'avance pas
donc après noël tandis que si je suis un
mouvement je dois persévérer dans nos
méthodes de mouvements ma vitesse va
rester constante c'est pas le cas en
pratique puisqu'on voit très bien que si
je fais rien la voiture ralentit moi
c'est bon c'est bon je fais une vidéo
youtube
désolé et du coup l'expérience se
contredit la première loi de newton
premières lois de newton est en fait
quasiment jamais vérifié mais ça c'est à
cause des frottements de l'air puisque
les frottement de l'air sont des forces
qui agissent sur la voiture qui existent
tout le temps à partir enfin quasiment
tout le temps partir du moment où on est
en mouvement et du coup la première loi
de newton n'a pas vraiment d'équivalent
en pratique donc on est un petit peu
plus dans l'espace où le vide est bien
meilleur il ya beaucoup moins de fretin
mais techniquement il ya toujours un peu
fou de frottement du coup ça s'est mis à
mu en de se dire que la première loi de
l'union sonne n'est jamais applicable en
pratique et si newton l'aï lancé c'est
bien sûr parce qu'ils avaient adopté
cette pensée gallienne dont j'ai parlé
dans le biographique sur la vie de
galilée notamment cette idée sur
laquelle que pour mieux comprendre notre
monde réel il est très très très utile
d'oublier les parties du réel de
s'abstraire du réel de partir dans un
monde imaginaire dans un monde
mathématiques vraiment des idées où tout
fonctionne très bien
et bizarrement le sait le pari de gagner
selon le mathématiques permet de bien
mieux comprendre le monde réel que si on
était resté dans le monde réel
ça c'est magique
la deuxième loi de newton qui elle est
plus importante
elle dit que la faute si j'applique une
force la voiture devant la voiture va
accélérer de façon constante et ça c'est
aussi très contraire ce qu'on voit dans
l'observer en pratique encore une fois
que du frottement de l'air en pratique
les si je garde le pied sur
l'accélérateur autour de même niveau
la vitesse de la voiture va se
stabiliser
brawn a l'impression qu'en pratique la
force que l'on met sur l'accélérateur en
cave en détermine non pas l'accélération
de la voiture mais sa vitesse et ça ça
vient du fait que les frottement de
l'air aux brillantes avec la vitesse de
la voiture donc
imaginons que je partais de zéro que
j'accélère est tranquillement que je
garde le pied sur l'accélérateur tu
joues avec la haine même même même
niveau alors la voiture d'accélérer mais
les frottement de l'air vont augmenter
au fur et à mesure que voitures avancent
vite à mesure que la vitesse est grande
et enfin qu'il va arriver à un point où
la vitesse va être tels que les
frottement de l'air vont parfaitement
compensé
l'accélération qui est dû à fait que
j'appuie sur l'accélérateur et du coup
ma vitesse au final va être déterminé
par les frottements donc en pratique à
cause des frottements de nerfs il est
très vrai de dire que la force avec un
pic à la voiture déterminent la vitesse
de la voiture et non son accélération et
c'est ça c'est vrai uniquement en
pratique à cause des frottements de
l'air en théorie dans le monde d'idées à
des idées de l'univers mathématiques la
physique théorique plus tôt ainsi avait
pas de frottement de l'air la force
qu'on applique détermine l'accélération
et non la vitesse
enfin la troisième loi de newton qui est
vraiment pu le mettre où surtout dans le
cas des voitures je vais vous demander
qu'est ce qui fait avancer la voiture
c'est une question intéressante
quelle est la force qui fait avancer la
voiture car bon c'est pas le fait que
j'appuie sur un petit bouton en bas ça
ça va pas faire avancer la voiture à
moteur est coupé ça fait pas vendre sa
voiture c'est pas le moment de plus le
moteur qui fait avancer la voiture qui
génère la force qui fait avancer la
voiture puisque valve motors c'est un
truc qui tourne et s'applique pas une
force qui nous pousse vers l'avant
en fait ce qui fait avancer la voiture
c'est un truc assez remarquable
versez-la que je sors donc en fait ce
qui fait avancer la voiture ce qui fait
que la voiture peut accélérer
c'est une force qui vient du sol ça
c'est surprenant c'est le seul qui fait
avancer la voiture
en fait la roue quand elle se met à
tourner donc à l'heure où est entraîné
par le moteur pour tourner et quand la
roue tourne au contact avec le sol va
d'avoir des frottements ça va ça va
moins ça va frotter et du coup ces
frottements vont faire que le seul la
ville à l'heure où la voiture va pousser
le sol et ce qui est un instrument c'est
là
et donc la route pousse sur le sol elle
pousse avec une force qui peut être
assez grande anse il appuie fortement
sur l'auteur et la troisième loi de
newton
elle nous dit que la force avec laquelle
le lard ou pousse le sol va venir va
être associé avec une force avec
laquelle le sol pousse la voiture et
c'est cette force qui fait avancer la
voiture j'ai toujours entendu que pour
illustrer à 3 mg newton faut il parler
de fusée barzan j'ai pas de fuser sous
la main tu peux prévu un voyage
interstellaire jours à venir du coup
j'ai dit serait à ça avec émotion mais
ça marche très bien avec la voiture
aussi en fait plus on pousse le sol avec
les roues de la voiture plus le sol va
venir pousser la voiture également et
vous faire avancer quoi ça c'est lisa
see my geek est en fait cette force à
deux patronnes de loi de newton c'est la
même force avec laquelle les roues des
voitures pousse le sol est la même que
la force avec laquelle le sol plus la
voiture c'est vraiment génial
c'est vraiment super contre intuitif on
a l'impression que le sol va plus poussé
la voiture que l' inverse puisque la
voiture on la voit avancer alors que le
sol
on le voit pas reculer façon que la
terre pousse plus sur la lune que la
lune ne pousse sur la terre avec la
gravité et ça c'est en théorie
newtonienne c'est complètement fou
forces de la terre sur la lune est la
même que la force de la lune sur la
terre remarquable incroyable surprenant
me semble que trop souvent lorsque l'on
apprend les lois de newton
on a tendance à les apprendre de manière
très scolaire c'est à dire qu'on les
apprend par coeur sans vraiment prendre
le temps de vraiment comprendre de
vraiment vraiment sentir le message qui
est caché derrière ses fameuses lois de
newton et en particulier on a tendance à
ne pas chercher à vouloir faire un lien
entre les lois théorique de newton et le
monde réel le monde de tous les jours où
ces lois s'appliquent mais de façon un
peu cachée du coup ne s'applique pas
directement
or faire l'effort de faire ce
c'est ce qui permet vraiment de sentir
ses lois et en particulier c'est en
faisant ça bien des années après midi en
un cours de physique que je me suis
enfin rendu compte qu'il n'y avait en
fait qu'une seule loi de newton et pas 3
tu pas si vous voyez de quoi je veux
parler
en fait la première la troisième loi de
newton sont des conséquences de la
deuxième loi qui est la loi fondamentale
de la théorie newtonienne pour commencer
la première loi n'est qu'une application
de la seconde loi de newton
en effet la deuxième loi dit que
l'accélération d'un objet se fait dans
la direction des forces que l'on
applique sur l'objet donc si l'on
applique aucune force aucune
accélération ne se fera dans aucune
direction
l'accélération sur un nul or ne pas
accélérer
c'est exactement la même chose que
persévérer dans son état de mouvements
en fait je doute même de l'utilité
d'enseigner la première loi de newton
notamment parce que lorsqu'on essaie de
l'enseigné de façon un peu rigoureuse
avec des termes comme référentiel
galiléen au mouvement une mire ciel tout
devient vite compliqué où on en arrive
parfois même à avoir des définitions
circulaire comme le montre très bien
vigilant hunt et du cou à cette première
loi de newton paraît super compliqué
alors qu'elle dit un truc qui est pas si
important que ça puisqu'il ce n'est
qu'une conséquence de la deuxième loi de
newton qui est la loi super importante
de la le principe fondamental de
dynamique parfois comme on l'appelle est
donc je me demande s'il ne vaudrait pas
mieux uniquement enseigner cette
deuxième loi de newton et en déduire en
exercice la première loi de newton
ceci dit je n'ai jamais enseigné les
lois de newton donc j'ai très peu
d'expérience pédagogique à ce sujet donc
si vous êtes enseignant notamment
j'adorerais avoir votre avis au sujet de
cette question donc s'il vous plaît
mettez un commentaire dites moi ce que
vous en pensez
dites moi que ce que j ai complètement
ridicule si c'est ridicule ça nous
permettrait aussi de progresser d'un
point de vue pédagogique
en attendant comme promis voici la
preuve que la troisième loi de newton
n'est qu'une conséquence de la deuxième
considérons une pomme une pastèque
isolée du monde extérieur alors le
système pomme + pastèque est un système
isolé donc son centre de masse persévère
aura dans son mouvement
s'il était immobile alors il restera
immobile or la position de ce centre de
masse est une somme pondérée de la
position de la pomme et de la position
de la pastèque ou les coefficients de
pondération sont les masses respectives
des deux objets dérivés ont maintenant
deux fois cette expression après
quelques manipulations algébrique on
voit que l'accélération de la pomme fois
sa masse peut être égal à l'opposé de
l'accélération de la pastèque fois sa
masse or d'après la seconde loi de
newton ces deux expressions
correspondent respectivement à la force
de la pastèque sur la pomme et à la
force de la pomme sur la pastèque
on conclut donc que ces deux forces sont
de même intensité et de direction
composé autrement dit on a bien prouvé
la troisième loi de newton
à partir de ces deux premières lois
l'intérieur fois on a imaginé un débat
sur les centristes autour des anémies
615 et tomates rouges charrie mes
costumes qui sont pas franchement
d'époque et alors il ya surtout eu un
débat très intéressante aux olives et
bob ricard sur le principe de relativité
et la possibilité ou non de mesures et
notamment des forces d'inertie
d'entraînement à la surface de la terre
pire ici la terre tourne sur elle même
mais bon on devrait décoller de la terre
et moi cette accélération qui fait
décoller de la terre lorsqu'on est à la
surface de la terre
et voici quelque chose que l'on peut
mesurer avec une analyse dimensionnelle
a priori ce qui va rentrer en jeu ça va
être le rayon de la terre et le temps
que met la terre pour faire un tour sur
elle-même et on veut une accélération
qui est du mètre par seconde car et là
on a des maîtres et des secondes donc
pouvoir les mettre par simon carré il
faut diviser le maître par les seconds
au carré c'est à dire prendre le rayon
de la terre et le diviser par le temps
qu'il faut pour que la terre fasse un
tour sur elle même au carré et du coup
cet accès à son entraînement qui est dû
au fait qu on est dans un référentiel
sur terre qui tourne
il va être de l'ordre de grandeur du
rayon de la terre 6400 km pire ise par
le temps qu'il faut pour qu'elle fasse
un tour sur elle même au carré c'est à
dire 24 heures au carré on pourra voir
la valeur exacte cette accélération faut
multiplier tout ça par une constante qui
va être ici
tocard et où tout aussi 6.28 la peau
stand du cercle lorsque l'on fait des
calculs on voit que cette accélération
d'entraînement dû à la rotation de la
terre sur elle même veut être à peu près
trois millièmes de l'accélération du
auchan de pesanteur autant dire que bon
on le ressent pas quoi en tout cas on ne
ressent pas directement mais on peut
observer des effets indirects notamment
en observant l effet de coriolis
l'accélération de coheris elle est due
au fait que lorsqu'on est au niveau de
l'équateur ont fait une plus grande
distance que lorsque l'on est près des
pôles le parti au niveau de l'équateur
va être plus accéléré
que celle qui n'est pas au niveau de
l'équateur
du coup ça va faire tourner des grands
fluide
du coup si on applique ça à la masse
d'air à l'atmosphère ça va créer des
anticyclones qui vont tourner du coup
dans l'hémisphère nord dans le sens ça
c'est le bon sens anti horaire et dans
l'hémisphère sud
du coup les cyclos de tous dans le sens
horaire mais la discussion nos salles
pas là puisque oli se demande si
l'accélération d'entraînement dû à la
rotation de la terre autour du soleil
peut lui être mesurée donc encore une
fois vous pouvez faire une analyse
financière ou le calcul exact pour
calculer cette accélération
d'entraînement mais il faut aussi pour
ses au fait que le soleil exerce en
force de gravité donc se voir sur la
terre mais sur nous aussi
du coup il faut prendre en compte aussi
le chant de pesanteur du soleil quand on
calcule c'est le bilan des forces et en
particulier on peut se demander lequel
des deux est le plus fort à ce que c'est
l'accélération d'entraînement ou est-ce
que c'est l'accélération du auchan de
pesanteur du soleil et ça c'est une
question absolument génial tout je ne
vais pas vous donner la réponse
aujourd'hui qu'elle va être au coeur
d'une vidéo à venir
enfin tu titi tu dis que si je
travaillais ma diction mon élocution et
si je parle au public de cordoba
excellent alors j'attendrai le million
d'abonnés
non je parle pas encore suite j'espère
que vous avez aimé cette vidéo la
prochaine fois on va parler de la loi de
la gravitation de newton en particulier
la question à laquelle j'aimerais que
vous réfléchissiez c'est comment est-ce
que newton a su deviner cette loi de la
gravitation tous les terres notamment
qui a pas dans cette formule magique qui
décrit la force de gravité si vous avez
aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à liker à
la commenter à la partager c'est comme
ça que vous pourrez les sept chaînes
décoller pensez bien sûr à vous abonner
pour ne pas manquer les prochaines
vidéos et j'espère que je vous verrai la
prochaine fois
donc si j'ai bien compris une voiture
qui roule ses roues applique une force
derrière sur la route et du coup la
voiture avance vers l'avant exactement
une superbe vidéo de veritas y sommes à
ce sujet explique vraiment bien qu'elle
pense à important de comprendre les
préjugés que l'on a sur les erreurs
volontaires niveau intuitif sur le temps
de compréhension intuitive de la théorie
fonctionne au mieux comprendre la
théorie de boucle ce qui en fait est une
phrase aujourd'hui on prend un peu pour
acquis parce qu'on sait manipuler ces
dépressions chez vraiment